the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
but what do we have left once we abandon
the lie
chaos what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight Q&A video I released one of
these videos yesterday and as I said in
that video I wanted to make another one
that way I can answer a few more of the
questions you left me so instead of
wasting any time let's just jump right
into them this first question comes from
Neil when he says what will be Tyrians
role in this final season this is a
great question because Tyrion is one of
the most beloved characters but he's
kind of been on the sidelines for the
last couple seasons ever since tearing
and left King's Landing his story hasn't
been as exciting or interesting like it
used to be but that's just my opinion
with only one season to go what can
Tyrion do to help in the war against the
night king and most likely a war against
his sister Cersei Lannister well there
are two things I can see Tyrion doing to
help out personally I don't really
expect to see Tyrion doing much damage
on the battlefield although he has
fought before and he's even killed
people before but Tyrians best work
comes during the planning phases of the
battle
not only does Tyrion come up with good
strategies but he's also spent most of
his life reading books and this is where
I think Tyrion can excel I actually made
a video specifically about this just a
few months ago as we all know it's just
a matter of time before the night king
reaches Winterfell so as soon as Jon
Daenerys Tyrion and everyone else gets
to Winterfell they won't have much time
to waste they will need to prepare the
castle for war and armed everyone with
the dragonglass they've mined on
Dragonstone as of right now there are
two characters already at Winterfell who
I can see Tyrion working with right away
Sam and bran are there together and
they've already started to solve some of
the biggest questions we've had one of
which was whether or not Rhaegar and
Lyanna were married now that they've
gotten that out of the way it's time to
figure out how to defeat the knight Cain
bran has already downloaded basically
the entire history of the world and he
can also go back in time and see just
about anything all he needs to do is
know where to look and that's where Sam
and even Tyrion can come into play they
need to figure out how the White Walkers
were stopped during the first long night
if they can find out how it was done
back then then perhaps they could do
that again in one of Odin and stories
she said the last hero sought out the
children of the forest in order to stop
the others from killing everyone the
last hero did spend a long time trying
to find the children but he eventually
does find them right as the White
Walkers were about to close in on him
when the last he were finds the children
of the forest they are somehow able to
get the fighting to stop we don't know
what exactly happened but since the
White Walkers did not take over the
world they must have been successful to
a certain extent bran needs to look back
in time and see what the last he were a
day to get the fighting to stop and I'm
betting there gonna be some answers in
one of the books Sam took from the
Citadel right before he left they made
sure to show us Sam taking things from
the Citadel and that means they're gonna
be very important later in the story Sam
could search through everything by
himself if he wanted to but it would be
a hell of a lot easier if he had some
help and that's where tyrion lanister
can be put to good use
Samwell Tarly is well read but tyrion is
older than him enough betty's read a lot
more than him over the years even with
all the drinking and whoring his done if
Tyrion sees those books when it gets to
Winterfell he won't be able to help
himself and that's just one of the
things I think Tyrion could do to get
him more involved in the story however
there is a very good chance Jon might
need all of them on the battlefield but
that's not where Tyrion and Sam shined
their brightest they will be needed when
it comes time to gameplan now besides
that I think Tyrians biggest role will
come in the end after all the fighting
is over I've always believed that Tyrion
would survive the entire series and in
fact I would be shocked if he died so
with that being said I think Tyrians
biggest job will come during the
rebuilding phase most of Westeros will
look like a battlefield by the end of
the series and it's going to take a lot
of work for the Seven Kingdoms to truly
prosper again Tyrion will really be
needed during this time half of the
kingdoms will need restored new laws
will need to be made and new people will
need to be put into positions of power
to make sure Westeros stays civilized as
they try to recover from this new long
night I don't know if there will be one
king or queen in the end but I do
believe Tyrion will have a very high
position regardless they probably won't
have
time to show most of these things take
effect but I hope we're able to see some
of the beginning stages of this change
take place Daenerys has preached about
breaking the wheel for multiple seasons
now and I would like to see or do it
with Tyrion still on her side
Tyrion will be one of the founding
fathers of the new Westeros that's the
role I see him having at the end of the
season and beyond this next question
comes from Lulu and it says do you think
Varys is a Targaryen maybe that's why he
shaves his head this is a great question
because I personally believe Varys does
have the blood of the Dragon although I
think he's more likely to be a Blackfyre
than a Targaryen my friend gray area
actually made a video about this topic
not too long ago so I would highly
recommend checking out her video if you
want to know all of the details
surrounding this theory however I will
say just because he shaves his head it
doesn't mean he's hiding his identity
but we do know Varys is always hiding
something he is one sneaky son of a
[ __ ] they may never go into this in the
show because they didn't really set up
for this reveal but in the books it
probably will be revealed that Varys is
a Blackfyre and that's why he's trying
to get a dragon back on the throne I do
like the idea of Varys shaving his head
because he is hiding his blond hair it
does make sense when you stack up all of
the other evidence in this theory I have
also believed that this is why Varys was
mutilated by the sorcerer as a child we
know there are a lot of people in this
story who see the Targaryen and their
dragons as a threat to the realm
according to Marwyn the mage he says the
Citadel and its maesters are responsible
for the Dragons disappearing before we
also know Robert Baratheon wanted all of
the Targaryen is dead even though his
reasoning was more personal but this
isn't a new concept Varys was most
likely cut to prevent him from fathering
any children someone may have been
trying to prevent any black fires or
Targaryen z' from reproducing that's why
I think Varys was mutilated that way his
bloodline could come to an end but
that's just my guess there was also a
very interesting scene in the show when
tyrion and varys were travelling
together when Varys was taking Tyrion to
meet Daenerys they noticed a gathering
outside where a red priestess is
preaching to a crowd of people about the
Dragon Queen as Tyrion and Varys are
watching this happen the red priestess
looks over right at them
and the look she gave them was very
ominous but it made me think she knew
one of them had King's blood now if you
remember when Melisandre meets John she
immediately becomes interested in him
she stares at him every chance she gets
and she even says he has power in him
power in his blood it seems like they
always know someone has King's blood
whether they can sense it or see it in
the flames they just always seemed to
know and I think this scene with Tyrion
and Varys was proof of that because she
was looking right over at them because
of this reason in my opinion now you
could say she was looking at Tyrion
because it kind of was edited to appear
that way but you could also say she was
looking at Varys too because Varys may
have King's blood the blood of the
Dragon we already know Varys has been
connected with whirl or ever since he
was a boy it was a sorcerer who cut him
and he has hated magic ever since any
time Varys meets a red priestess they
take interest in him right away
kinvaras knows what the voice in the
flame said to Varys and I think
Melisandre knows as well which is how
she knew Varys was gonna die Varys is
not just a master of whisperers he
probably has King's blood and this is
why he has had this weird connection
with whirl or ever since he was a kid
blood magic is very powerful in this
story and if Varys has Kings blood that
makes him a very important character and
I think that's why alarms start to go
off anytime he meets a priest or
priestess because they know how powerful
his blood is the next question is from
Raider Nation and it says what's the
official story on Liana's death I'm
sorry if I'm being ignorant maybe I
missed it but what's the official story
of her death as far as the Seven
Kingdoms are concerned alright this is a
good question because some other people
may not know this thanks to Brian
Stark's vision we know for a fact that
lianna died during childbirth but what
did the people throw out the Seven
Kingdoms think because obviously Ned
couldn't tell people what really
happened or else they would be asking
him about the child she gave birth to
well I'm sure if you went around the
Seven Kingdoms and asked people how
Leone had died they would all probably
have their own version of the story but
for the most part people probably
believe that Rhaegar had killed her
since Ned never talked about what
happened at the tower everyone still
assumed that Rhaegar kidnapped her and
raped her which
to mately caused her death robert
baratheon believed that Rhaegar raped
her multiple times he even asked Ned
this question how many times do you
think Rhaegar raped your sister how many
hundreds of times
Robert assumed it had to have been a
brutal rape to cause her death which is
understandable since Ned did not tell
him what actually happened it's
unspeakable to you well her father dits
your family that was unspeakable
what Rhaegar Targaryen did to your
sister the woman I loved
kill every Targaryen I get my hands on
you can't get your hands on this one
Ned had to just sit there and allow him
to say these things because he couldn't
tell Robert what really happened
darrell's John would most likely be
killed because he had Targaryen blood
all of the stark children seemed to
believe the same story too brian says
Rhaegar carried her off and raped her
and Songz's says the same thing when
Psalms and Littlefinger were down in the
crypts in Winterfell Sansa says what
pretty much everyone throughout the
Seven Kingdoms believed
how many tens of thousands had to die
because Rhaegar chose your aunt yes he
chose her and then he kidnapped her and
raped her
that's Lyanna my father's sister King
Robert was supposed to marry her but
Rhaegar Targaryen kidnapped her Robert
started a war to win her back he killed
Rhaegar but she died anyway she said
Rhaegar kidnapped her and then he raped
her
since Ned found her in a bed of blood
people must just assume that it was a
brutal raping which is why Robert was so
furious this pissed him off so bad he
was willing to kill every single
Targaryen he ever got his hands on
since Ned never talked about lianna
everyone had to basically fill in all
the blanks for themselves so I am
guessing they all imagined the worst
Rhaegar was always held responsible for
Liana's death in the eyes of the people
but now we know what really happened the
next question has a spoiler in it so if
you do not want to know any spoilers I
would recommend stopping the video right
now the next question comes from bianca
funk and she says the actor who plays
Rhaegar was sighted in Belfast recently
do you think we will get another
flashback with Rhaegar like an actual
flashback where he talks if so what do
you think it will be about I'm hoping
for the Trident but I can also see them
doing the tournay and Harrenhal this is
a good question because of Rhaegar is in
the next season this could be a pivotal
scene for the end game I did make a
video about this update as soon as the
news came out about this the actor who
played Rea guard during brains flashback
was in Belfast and he took a selfie as
he was steaming in front of the hotel
where a lot of Game of Thrones actors
stay shortly after he posted the photo
he went back and deleted it because it
started to go viral within our community
if he is filming scenes then it
obviously has to be a flashback from
brand but what could he possibly be
doing that would help push the story
along there's only six episodes left so
we don't really have any time for filler
if they're gonna show Rhaegar again it
better be important unless Rhaegar has
magically still alive we don't need to
see him die that doesn't help tell the
end of the story in my opinion they
should have shown the battle at the
Trident a few seasons ago we also don't
need to see him hand Liana the Roses at
the tour neither because we already know
how that part of the story ends we know
they got together got married and had a
kid we need to learn something else
there is one thing I think they could do
that could be crucial to the story
for those of you that don't know Rhaegar
was actually really big in a prophecy he
was convinced that his son would be the
prince who was promised this prophecy
completely consumed him and it's one of
the things that led him to Liana many
people believe that it could have been
bloodraven or the children sending these
visions or dreams to Rhaegar whatever
sent him down this road and led him to
believe he needed to have another son
because he would end up becoming the
savior if this happens to be true then
we need to find this out because this
may result in the defeat of the night
king depending on what Sam finds in the
books from the Citadel bran may need to
go back and look into this prophecy to
see who will have to be the one to beat
the others for good when Rhaegar was a
boy he came across something in a book
that sent him on this journey of
fulfilling the prophecy whatever he did
read completely changed his outlook on
life and bran may need to find out what
that is
bran could also go back and see Liana
and regards private conversations
because there must have been a time when
Rhaegar told Liana about this prophecy
and how they needed to make a son
together Jon may need to know this to
realize it has to be him who faces off
against the night king one verse one
even though Daenerys has dragon power
you have to keep in mind the others are
a part of John's story not really
Danny's Danny didn't become involved in
this story until season seven this has
been John's story ever since season one
Jon realized the truth about the White
Walkers being real all the way back then
now he will need Danny's help in
defeating them but her true story will
end with the fight over the Iron Throne
that's been a part of her since the
beginning while on the other hand the
White Walkers have been a part of John
since the beginning I think it will be
up to John to stop the night king but he
obviously won't do it alone and it will
be ultimately up to Danny to taking the
Iron Throne from Cersei and she won't do
that alone either they both have their
own parts to play into telling of the
ending of this great story even though
John and Daenerys are together they
still have their own stories to tell I
think the Starks will be the ones who
defeat the night King because they have
been connected ever since they were
created but these are just my opinions
and you have to always remember I know
nothing let me know what you think about
the questions in today's video what are
your opinions on these topics put your
thoughts down below in the comment
section I want to thank everyone for
watch
the video I always appreciate that and
also want to give a huge shout out to
everyone on patreon as well thank you
all so much for your support I hope you
all have a great day I'll see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]